voilà et nous en revenons maintenant au
tour de france qui je vous le disais en
début de ce journal a été gagnée comme
prévu par laurent fignon
alors que l'étape du jour la dernière a
été remportée par le suisse gilbert glos
on a eu un peu peur cet après-midi sur
les pavés des champs elysées qu'elle
était mouillée ce qui a donné plusieurs
chutes spectaculaires mais la hiérarchie
établie après l'étape contre la montre
de dijon n'a en rien été bousculé et la
foule énorme qui a suivi à paris
l'arrivée du tour n'a pas été déçu celui
qu'elle attendait était au rendez-vous
et celui là c'était bien
laurent laurent fignon
c'était un beau tour de france très
chaud ça vous a rappellé souvenir oui
mon premier tour de france par un en
ligue 2 n'a vraiment rien
qui s'est finie en lutte
vraiment c'est un grand champion il
mesure combien je sais pas vous savez
qui a gagné le tour date et non c'est
hinault qui a gagné tour il va gagner le
tour il va gagner tourbe
est-ce qu'il a eu du mal à gagner le
tour oh non pas tellement
est ce que vous connaissez laurent
fignon
bon c'est à dire et c'est à dire bon
j'ai c'est un vieux même pas ce que
c'est qu'un vélo
c'est un bon gars et enfin l'arrivée de
cette dernière étape du tour de france
alors messieurs vous avez suivi le tour
de france a vu je suis de l'avant dit
vous avez suivi le tour de france le
rouennais dit tout à voir qu'est ce que
vous pensez du tour de france 80 de ses
chiens vous trouvez que ça a été un joli
tour de franc joué jusqu'à gagner ses
prisons comment ai-je horizon non pas
fillon fignon fignon ça s'écrit f
ign au n fignon c'est le nouveau
champion d'un nouveau tour le dernier
mais de loin le plus rétro et le plus
passionnant de ces dix dernières années
et quand un maillot jaune arrive sur les
champs-elysées que craint-il sinon une
chute et pour ce maillot jaune l'anxiété
est encore plus grande lorsque une
averse tombe sur les pavés poussiéreux
et quand l'averse tombe les coureurs
aussi c'est presque fatal et iops
hotmail en sait quelque chose
au fait où et fignon on a vu wind m mais
le voilà fignon et c'est bon signe
on l'a cherché avec inquiétude ce
coureur dont les cheveux sont de la même
couleur que le maillot le voilà
rassurant non
et puis c'est le dernier tour et puis
c'est formidable formidable parce que
pascal jules démarre jules qu'on appelle
déjà julo imaginer une victoire de julo
le copain de fignon sur les
champs-elysées où une apothéose ce
serait une apothéose
mais jules et rejoint et arrive le
dernier passage sur la place de la
concorde hinault à gagner sur les champs
elysées l'an passé laurent fignon pense
qu'il n'y a aucune raison pour ne pas
faire de même
il démarre
il démarre mais kelly a pris sa roue
suivi par le suisse glaus
et puis comme d'habitude c'est le sprint
sur les champs-elysées
et kelly qui tente de remonter glaus
mais klaus qui passe d'un boyau
glaus bas donc kelly mais fignon passe à
22 ans il est avec felice gimondi le
plus jeune vainqueur du tour de france
de l'après guerre
il portait le dossard numéro 15 c'est
celui de la voiture de prost fignon
prost cela ne vous dit rien